but would begin this morning with new
threats by President Trump regarding the
partial federal government shutdown now
in its third week the president now says
he's willing to let the shutdown last
for months or even years following a
meeting with congressional leaders on
Friday the president also suggested he
could build the wall without
congressional approval by declaring a
national emergency mola Lengai is at the
White House with the latest mola good
morning well good morning
vice president Mike Pence will lead
staff meetings here at the White House
today and continue negotiations but
without a vote scheduled in the Senate
until next Tuesday roughly 800,000
federal workers will have to wait at
least four more days without any
indication of when they might see their
next paycheck I don't know how to shut
down I call it doing what you have to do
President Trump said that may mean
keeping the government closed for months
or even years if we have to stay out for
a very long period of time we're going
to do that he dug in on demands for his
key campaign promise and insisted for
the first time that he won't let
Congress be the barrier to building a
wall I may do it but we could call a
national emergency and build it very
quickly a national emergency would lit
the president tap pentagon funds to
begin wall construction without
congressional approval Nancy Pelosi the
new Democratic speaker spoke out in an
interview to air on CBS's Sunday morning
I think that effectively what he would
like to say is it doesn't matter what
Congress sends me it just matters what I
insisted upon but with both sides
steeled for a fight the president
appeared to bend on what a border wall
may look like if I build this wall or
fence or anything that Democrats need to
call it if I build a steel wall rather
than a concrete wall it will actually be
stronger still President Trump and top
Democrats he merged from a meeting
unable even to agree if they're making
progress we had a very very productive
meeting lengthy and sometimes
contentious conversation and the new
House speaker also faced a contentious
conversation in her
ranks after one new high-profile
Democrat in Congress rashida to leave
made this profane remark about the
president he sum up President Trump
called that highly disrespectful you
don't impeach people when they're doing
a good job and you don't a people when
there was no collusion still Speaker
Pelosi defended her fellow Democrat I
don't think it's anything worse than the
president has what the president has
said but added she'll wait for special
counsel robert muller to finish his work
and that headache hanging over this
White House isn't going away in the New
Year or with the new Congress as the
Special Counsel investigating Russian
interference in the 2016 presidential
election just asked for a six-month
extension to finish his work Michelle it
goes on and on mullah thank you well you
can see all of Jane Pauley's interview
with House Speaker Nancy Pelosi tomorrow
on CBS Sunday morning